Pues en Washington y en los Estados
aledaños en Maryland y Virginia que son
los estados que se puede votar en esta
área metropolitana teniendo en cuenta
que en Washington no se puede votar
Washington el distrito de Colombia no
tiene representación para las votaciones
legislativas al menos sin embargo pues
van a ver votaciones locales van a haber
votaciones locales en 36 gobernaciones y
más de 80 alcaldías de ciudades
principales en todo el país el primer
estado en abrir votaciones fue Vermont
que lo hizo a las 6 de la mañana después
se vinieron el resto de estados de la
costa este que a las 7 de la mañana hora
local hora de Washington empezó la
votación recordemos que en juego está
pues no solamente la mayoría acá en el
legislativo sino en otros cargos
estatales muy importantes que van a
terminar definiendo la legislación
electoral el aborto y muchas de las
políticas económicas en Estados Unidos
el presidente Joe biden ayer en uno de
los últimos discursos dijo que veía muy
apretada la carrera a la cámara de
representantes que sería muy difícil que
el partido demócrata mantuviese la
mayoría en la cámara de representantes
sin embargo el senado está en juego hay
estados muy importantes donde se va a
terminar definiendo esta elección como
lo son Pensilvania Arizona y Nevada
sobre todo Pensilvania donde es un tiro
al aire como dicen expertos sobre Quién
ganará esa silla que podría definir si
el partido demócrata mantiene la mayoría
en el senado o si los republicanos
además de tomarse posiblemente la cámara
de representantes también terminen con
el control en el senado la gran cuestión
de hoy Cristóbal Qué efectos pueden
tener para la economía estas elecciones
de medio mandato
pues ya los grandes presidentes de las
grandes empresas acá en Estados Unidos
pues han visto con preocupación la cifra
de crecimiento económico de hecho Fox
news dice que técnicamente Estados
Unidos ya estaría en una recesión porque
dos en dos trimestres seguidos se ha
presentado un decrecimiento económico
sin embargo Pues el empleo en Estados
Unidos hacía mantenido boyante ha
aumentado la cifra de empleos
disponibles pero este empleo Y estos
salarios no han podido atrapar o
alcanzar la inflación que supera el 8%
en Estados Unidos y precisamente eso
Este es el factor principal de estas
elecciones la inflación el poder
adquisitivo de los estadounidenses que
se ha visto muy afectado a pesar de que
el tema el tema de empleo el tema de
capitalización de los bancos ha sido
positivo pero ese bolsillo esa inflación
es lo que va a llevar a muchos a salir a
votar y es lo que terminará esté
afectando Wall Street que pues está
bastante pendiente de cómo sea el
desarrollo electoral de estas elecciones
recordemos que en algunos estados Pues
hay amenazas de violencia muchos
simpatizantes
de votación precisamente para asegurarse
que el conteo sea el adecuado que las
que la votación pues tenga orden y no se
presente un supuesto fraude electoral
como ellos siguen alegando Esto entonces
pues como ambiente político en todo el
país que obviamente nosotros desde
Francia 24 estaremos reportando